>> Greg: TUESDAY, 18
REPUBLICAN HOUSE MEMBERS
NOMINATED TRUMP FOR THE NOBEL
PRIZE.
SHOULD TRUMP SHARE THE AWARD IF
INDEED HE WINS?
WE HEAR ABOUT KIM, PRESIDENT XI,
MOON.
WHAT ABOUT THE WORM?
DENNIS RODMAN CLAIMS KIM JONG UN
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND TRUMP UNTIL
RODMAN GAVE HIM "THE ART OF THE
DEAL" LAST YEAR.
THE BOOK LED TO A CHANGE OF
HEART.
>> I THINK HIS IMPRESSION ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> Greg: TRUMP IS GOING TO
MEET WITH KIM AND MAY BE
AMERICAN HOSTAGES MIGHT BE
RELEASED.
IT'S PRETTY AMAZING NEWS.
WE WENT TO CNN AND MSNBC FOR
RESPONSE.
>> NO, PLEASE.
PLEASE DON'T SAY THAT.
>> Greg: THEY HATE ANY GOOD
NEWS ABOUT TRUMP.
RODMAN MAY BE THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION'S MOST SUCCESSFUL
DIPLOMAT.
MAKES YOU WONDER, SHOULD OBAMA
HAVE SENT PEYTON MANNING TO TALK
TO PUTIN?
ALEX RODRIGUEZ TO CHINA, JOHNNY
MANDEL TO TEHRAN?
ANYTHING COULD'VE WORKED.
AS LONG AS THEY HAD A COPY OF
THE BOOK.
THEY WOULD HAVE DONE BETTER THAN
HILLARY AND SAMANTHA POWER.
AS FAR AS THOSE THREE HOSTAGES,
WHO IS A BETTER NEGOTIATOR?
OBAMA AND HILLARY OR TRUMP AND
RODMAN.
WE ALL KNOW I HAVE AS MUCH
CHANCE OF WINNING THAT AS TRUMP
DOES.
THE EXACT QUALITIES THAT TURN
OFF LARS IN OSLO.
NO MATTER WHAT, TRUMP AND RODMAN
HAS GOTTEN US FURTHER WITH THE
NUCLEAR THREAT THAN ALL OF THE
BELTWAY DABBLERS OUT THERE.
MAYBE THEY SHOULD READ THE BOOK
TOO.
DANA, YOU ARE AT THE TABLE WHEN
I CALLED DENNIS RODMAN A LITTLE
B WORD BECAUSE HE WENT TO
NORTH KOREA.
MY MEA CULPA.
I THINK I WAS WRONG, AND I
SHOULD APOLOGIZE TO DENNIS
RODMAN.
HE'S AN AMERICAN HERO.
>> Dana: I THINK YOU SHOULD
RESERVE YOUR JUDGMENT.
I WONDER HOW JOHN KERRY ESCAPED
THE MONOLOGUE.
>> Greg: HE MOVES VERY SLOW.
HE BLENDED INTO THE WOODEN
BACKGROUND THAT I DIDN'T SEE HIM
BACKGROUND THAT I DIDN'T SEE HI
HIM.
>> Dana: WHO DID HE TAKE ON?
JAMES TAYLOR TO PARIS.
>> Greg: AMERICA WAS HAPPY
BECAUSE JAMES TAYLOR WAS NOT IN
THE COUNTRY FOR A FEW DAYS.
>> Dana: I THINK IF IN THE
LONG RUN WE ACTUALLY DO FIND A
PEACEFUL SOLUTION HERE, WHICH
THERE IS A LONG WAY TO GO, THEN
OF COURSE PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOULD
BE GRANTED, WARDEN, EXCUSE ME.
THE NOBEL PEACE PRIZE.
I ALSO THINK ONE OF THE BIG
THINGS AND THE REASON I DON'T
THINK DENNIS RODMAN DESERVE SO
MUCH CREDIT IS THE STRATEGIC
PLAN TO SQUEEZE CHINA AND GET
CHINA TO GET LITTLE ROCKET MAN
TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
THAT'S THE BRILLIANCE OF THIS
WHOLE PLAN.
>> Greg: WHO STARTED THAT,
KIMBERLY?
A MAN NAMED DONALD TRUMP.
>> Kimberly: THE ART OF THE
DEAL.
FOLLOWING THIS TRAIN OF THOUGHT,
DENMAN THIS
DENNIS RODMAN WAS ABLE TO CHANGE
THE MIND-SET OF KIM JONG UN.
OPEN TO THE CHARMS OF POTUS AND
HE THEREFORE SAID YOU KNOW WHAT,
I'M GOING TO STOP BEING A BAD
ACTOR AND I'M GOING TO GET IT
TOGETHER.
AND I'M GOING TO SHAKE HANDS AND
WORK WITH SOUTH KOREA, AND I'M
GOING TO RELEASE HOSTAGES, AND
I'M GOING TO STOP RUNNING AROUND
BEING LITTLE ROCKET MAN.
>> Greg: I WAS THINKING, JUAN,
YOU SHOULD GO TO IRAN WITH MY
BOOK AND I THINK THAT WOULD
SOLVE EVERYTHING.
>> Jesse: MIGHT NOT EVER COME
BACK.
IS THAT YOUR IDEA?
>> Greg: IT IS A WIN-WIN
EITHER WAY.
>> Juan: OH, MY GOD.
IT COULD WORK.
ANYTHING FOR GREG, YOU KNOW THAT
ANYTHING FOR GREG, YOU KNOW THA
THAT.
>> Jesse: ANOTHER HOSTAGES
WERE GOING TO HAVE TO GET.
>> Dana: WE WILL GET RIGHT ON
IT.
>> Juan: JESSE CAN BE MY SEAL.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE NEVER
GETTING OUT THEN.
>> Juan: STRUCK BY DENNIS
RODMAN.
I THINK IT'S WONDERFUL.
I THINK YOU ARE HAVING FUN.
>> Kimberly: HE IS SERIOUS.
>> Juan: WHAT YOU SAID IS
SERIOUS, KIMBERLY.
>> Greg: WE TALK ABOUT HOW
BOOK CAN CHANGE YOUR LIFE.
>> Dana: WHAT HAPPENED BETWEEN
THE BOOK AND NOW?
HE ACTUALLY GOT NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
>> Greg: WELL, THAT IS THE ART
OF THE DEAL.
NEGOTIATION.
THE ART OF THE DEAL IS RIGHT UP
THERE.
A FEW YEARS AGO YOU WOULD'VE
SAID DONALD TRUMP AND DENNIS
RODMAN, WITH THE SUPPORT OF
KANYE WEST, WERE ENDING THE
KOREAN WAR, I WOULD'VE DROPPED
DEAD.
IT'S INCREDIBLE.
>> Kimberly: CHECK YOUR PULSE.
>> Jesse: THE MIDDLE EAST,
SEND RODMAN.
MAYBE THEY CAN SHARE THE PEACE
PRIZE.
EVERYTHING IS HAPPENING FOR A
REASON.
>> Greg: ON A SERIOUS POINT,
WE HEAR OF THE IMMINENT RELEASE
OF THESE HOSTAGES.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
MIKE POMPEO WHEN HE WAS THERE
AND HE MET WITH KIM JONG UN, IT
WAS PROBABLY A CONDITION, AND
ALSO JOHN BOLTON, THE NEW
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR.
WE ARE NOT -- REMEMBER BOWE
BERGDAHL AND THE TRADE?
NOT A GOOD TRADE.
IT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
THERE'S NO POSSIBLE WAY
PRESIDENT TRUMP WOULD BE WILLING
TO MEET WITH SOMEBODY WHO WAS
HOLDING AMERICANS HOSTAGE IN A
LABOR CAMP.
IN ORDER TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN,
THEY HAVE TO BE RELEASED.
TWO OF THEM WERE TAKEN HOSTAGE
IN 2017, ONE BEFORE THAT, I
THINK 2015.
APPARENTLY THEY ARE AT A HOTEL
NOW.
THEY HAVE BEEN MOVED FROM THE
CAMP TO A HOTEL.
WHEN WE MEET THEM.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE VERY
INTERESTING AND IT WILL PROBABLY
TAKE YEARS TO GET ALL THE
INFORMATION.
IMAGINE WHAT WE MIGHT LEARN FROM
THEM ABOUT HOW KIM JONG UN
ACTUALLY WORKS.
I WANT TO TAP THE BRAKES ON THIS
IDEA THAT KIM JONG UN SHOULD
SHARE IN A NOBEL PEACE PRIZE.
HE'S A HORRIBLE PIECE IN.
>> Juan: WE HAD RELEASES IN
'09 WITH BILL CLINTON AND UP '
'10.
THIS IS WHAT THE PEOPLE AT STATE
AND OTHERS SAY, IT'S PART OF HIS
BEHAVIOR.
THIS IS HOW HE PLAYS THE GAME.
HE MAKES OFFERS.
IT'S NOT CLEAR WHAT OUR STRATEGY
IS, GOING IN.
I SEE SOME PEOPLE WANT TO
CELEBRATE EARLY.